I was you who wouldn't want to be meghan
trainor right now she just kicked off
her US tour and the house has been
packed with fans singing along to every
single hit it's all about that bass but
it's also all about getting a big
exclusive an all-access pass to join
Meghan backstage have a good night
before slaying it in Seattle backstage a
meet-and-greet and yes Meghan's wearing
a onesie yeah I don't need to wear Spanx
Meghan told me some of her fans getting
real emotional like the last girl she's
just a mess and I was like here we go
this is our one opportunity to get an
amazing selfie right now okay so we're
gonna lick our teeth and we're gonna
wipe these tears and we're gonna have
the best smile we got are you ready
because making calls this the
untouchable tour in support of her album
thank you and she's clearly living a
dream last night I went to DC factory
and my security guard was like - I'm
Nicole breathing I was like no dude like
it's cheesecake I'll be fine I walked in
there got swarmed I was like huh maybe I
should have had you come with me sorry
Megan you are famous you're on the cover
of Billboard magazine is because of
present for you that billboard story
made some folks think she wouldn't be
voting in the upcoming election
yeah the contacts I'm here to clear it
up what's up murca I wanted to learn
more about both parties cuz it's one of
the biggest elections of all times and
it's such a big deal and and I figured
it out and I'm ready yeah right about
and she's ready to start looking for
that dear future husband double dating
with her bestie Chloe grace Moretz and
hoes guy Brooklyn Beckham I'm that
person that's like where's my boyfriend
where is he why can't you find him what
do you look for the guy I love a sweet
sweet sweet guy who's nice that like
will open the door for you and stuff
love that stuff and he's got to download
your music from whatever he's got to
know my song all right let me explain
that cuz Megan told me that she once had
a boyfriend who would not spend a buck
29 to download all about that base so
she was all about hit the road jack good
for her she is supportive man